oh [ __ ] hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to turbo
dismount there's been a lot of updates
since the last time I played and a lot
of damn it god I'm terrible at
everything Brian man
oh hey where'd my hands go wide it's
just my hands oh no my hands my bike oh
well that was less impressive than I
thought it'd be I'll just sit here with
broken pelvis
don't mind me oh oh oh oh come on
officer yeah all right oh [ __ ] I forgot
the mines are gonna clear out all the
things
Oh God yeah Oh what happens what oh oh
oh this making it oh my god
Cooper go I forgot you can kind of fly
well [ __ ] Oh took off without me well it
took off with some of me but not enough
this is gonna go good they're gonna go
the best oh wait I see a problem here
I'm to save the shortcut don't mind me
I'll be on my way
Oh God super speedy can it make it well
if I could do that faster oh it did go
fast what happened it looks so much less
horrific when it's just that floating
thing all right what do we got here I
could have made that bigger but I guess
I didn't oh then fits so weirdly
perfectly oh my god
that is so scary that is the scariest
thing I've ever seen oh no my man I'm
just driving my tractor down oh is that
the police you'll never take me alive
oh god it's so weird it's so weird it's
so weird yeah alright then
oh god wastelander from Mad Max not bad
not bad at all
oh god I'm steering whoa steering's a
little loose okay oh [ __ ] that's
impossible
what would anyone do that
Oh God how about the boogie bus I always
like the boogie bus oh that's right you
hump the boogie bus
I forgot that those you're Pro man he is
enjoying that way too much alright let's
go buddy go on hump your way into
destiny through the guitar oh he humped
his little heart out he humped to his
heart's content YUM death that's what he
did
humping his last pelvis again again
again buddy
oh god is so bad it's so bad I look so
weird oh it's so weird and wrong Oh God
hey here we go baby here we go miss diva
Oh God did not work at all yep that's
what I thought sorry sorry sorry okay so
that's all the turbo dismount for now it
has been a long time since I played this
game and I kind of forgot about it for a
while there but I do enjoy playing it
just because it's so silly and brutal so
if you enjoy it and want to see me play
some more let me know down in the
comments below I will if you want me to
and I haven't even gotten to all the
vehicles yet so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video